[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros este
8 de marzo es el día internacional de
los derechos de la mujer en esta fecha y
como corresponde todo el año france24
abre sus micrófonos a las que defienden
nuestros derechos y la lucha por la
igualdad mi nombre es ángela gómez ya
que inicia una nueva entrevista de cinco
minutos con le honores a la bata ella es
colombiana indígena comisionada de los
derechos humanos del resguardo awá co de
la sierra nevada' comprometida con la
causa medioambiental
leonor bienvenido a france 24 y comienzo
preguntándole por su trabajo la obra de
su vida ha sido transmitir el mensaje de
los hermanos mayores y de las
autoridades tradicionales de la sierra
nevada de santa marta
esto en defensa de los derechos
colectivos y derechos ambientales cual
es un mensaje
muchísimas gracias a este canal son 24
efectivamente yo soy del pueblo awá oso
jaguar acá tengo una dedicado mi vida
puesta a la defensa de nuestros deberes
como indígenas que son como ardua hash
que me identifica y exactamente nosotros
tenemos una gran expectativa que no nace
con las personas sino que meritoria de
reivindicaciones de defensas por un
medio ambiente por una cultura por una
espiritualidad que son los aportes que
nosotros podemos hacerle a la humanidad
y yo creo que estos derechos colectivos
y estos derechos ambientales tienen que
ver con la cultura de los pueblos tienen
que ver con esos espacios que para
nosotros son sagrados bueno precisamente
cuál es la importancia de esta defensa
suya del territorio y cuéntanos cómo ha
sido esa trascendencia internacional a
través de su labor
e
en un colectivo que tiene unas raíces
tradicionales que tiene un interés
colectivo ningún ningún trabajo se hace
solo es colectivo y por lo tanto uno
hace parte de ese liderazgo pero la
actividad la acción por las metas que
hemos alcanzado del poder trascender
siempre ha dependido del colectivo
gracias a estas prácticas a esas
costumbres gracias a este territorio que
defendemos por un medio lente por un los
recursos naturales que no son recursos
sino que son elementos fundantes de una
cultura de un espíritu colectivo que
encontramos en todos los pueblos
indígenas con culturas propias con
lenguas propias con
y espíritu propio este 8 de marzo con el
auspicio de la embajada de francia la
vamos a ver participar en una mesa
redonda con activistas de argentina y
méxico- para hablar de los derechos
medioambientales y porque leonor la
acción de las mujeres es clave en este
tema
la acción de los seres muy claves en el
tema de la defensa del medio ambiente
porque los detalles de la vida lo
esencial lo significativo que es criar
un hijo
permanentemente desde la desde el
vientre de la madre hasta volver otra
vez a la madre esa mujer es esa
humanidad tenemos una incidencia desde
antes de nacer las personas y yo creo
que eso hace posible tener una humanidad
tener un colectivo siempre a favor de la
de una cultura que hace que el medio
ambiente no sea sabe que es el medio
ambiente no solamente proteja los
pueblos indígenas ni los territorios
indígenas también es trasciende a la
humanidad trasciende a otras sociedades
y yo creo que nosotros hacemos con
nuestras formas de vida con nuestros
usos y costumbres una una un ambiente
que repercute en bien de la sociedad
nacional de la del mundo
hacer posible mejorar aportarle a una
situación de cambios climáticos si es
necesario realmente mantener los valores
de la tierra los valores de los recursos
para poder seguir siendo y poder
garantizar a las futuras generaciones el
bienestar de vida que necesitamos todos
los humanos gracias a usted y volver a
la madre a través de los derechos
humanos sigan con nosotros en france 24
[Música]